[Music]
so our first theme of the day here is
what can philosophy tell us about
reality that science can't and philip
i'm going to bring you in here because
you laid out a few possible areas in in
science can you um elaborate on that for
us so i mean i think if you are a
follower of scientism which is excel
itself a philosophical position
and you think the only things we're
permitted to believe in are those that
can be experimentally verified then
there's not much of a role for
philosophy in uh finding out about the
nature of reality
the trouble is
if you're consistent in your scientism
you won't believe in your own conscious
experience because conscious experience
is not a postulation of experimental
science the philosopher daniel dennett
is wonderfully consistent in this
right he's a zealous believer in
scientism he appreciates that his own
conscious experience cannot be
experimentally verified so he doesn't
believe in it so i essentially think
there's no middle way between someone
like me and someone like dennett if
you're going to be consistent you either
drink the kool-aid with dennis
accept scientism deny the reality of
your conscious experience or you accept
that there are
non-empirical data by which i mean
information about reality that we know
independently of public observation
experiments such as the reality of your
own consciousness as soon as you admit
that then there's a crucial task for
philosophy which is taking the things we
know about empirically the things we
know about in these other ways bringing
them together and it's about time we got
back to that very important task
can you just can i push you even further
on the consciousness like
to clarify just make it easy for
everyone what what for you is it that
within consciousness that science can't
get at good so i think so i say we know
about consciousness in this special way
by attending to our own experiences and
when we do this we discover that our
experience involves qualities colors
sounds smells tastes qualities that
can't be captured in the purely
quantitative vocabulary of physical
science so if your description of the
brain is framed in the purely
quantitative vocabulary of neuroscience
you just miss out these qualities and
hence really miss out consciousness
itself and finally you know we shouldn't
be surprised about this because our as i
argue in my book galileo's error quick
plug that our current scientific
paradigm for the last 400 years was
designed to exclude consciousness at the
start of the scientific revolution
galileo wants this purely mathematical
quantitative science he appreciates that
the qualities we encounter in conscious
experience colors sounds smells tastes
can't be captured in these terms so he
says
well if we want a mathematical science
we've got to take the qualities of
consciousness out of the picture that
was a good move it was the start of
mathematical physics but when now it's
gone so well
we're now at a phase of history where
people like peter say it's gone so well
it's the truth of everything the irony
is
it's gone so well because it was
designed to be a partial description of
reality by galileo one that excludes the
qualitative reality of conscious
experience
what a load of nonsense
i suspected peter would come in here
i mean if you want an example of a
pessimism of a philosopher that was the
perfect example
we will never understand consciousness
let's focus on it
no no but let's focus on consciousness
because i think there are actually only
two serious problems in science that we
have not yet solved
one is the origin of everything which is
part of physics and mathematics and the
other is consciousness the way that our
brains generate this property is
property of matter
and
we are making progress we are built we
are
building machines that are edging not
only are we understanding the structure
of the brain and beginning to see how
bits of the brain in a kind of systems
way interact with each other
we are also beginning to build machines
that are on the edge of simulating
consciousness and once we have simulated
consciousness we will
master
other features such as julia mentioned
aesthetics why aesthetics is just a part
of consciousness once we've mastered
consciousness we shall master aesthetics
as well and we're edging towards doing
it we've got we we know that we can
build machines that can
emulate little bits of consciousness
that's happened over the last 20 years
what's going to happen over the next 200
years
so don't be as pessimistic as you you
were displaying
i'm tempted to bring you in here julian
because of the aesthetics coming in to
play there would you have a response to
aesthetics discussed sufficiently well
actually
this is an interesting one because i've
got more sympathy for that than that you
might have thought but i mean before i
sort of like
attack a position you may not be have
this let's clarify about values moral
values and ethical values so i don't
think they're going to build a sort of a
large values collider in in switzerland
soon right um but what so was did where
where where were your values going to
sit in this because i could think of a
couple of examples is it going to be the
case that
this is simply going to be a description
of the way the human mind works we're
simply going to find that we value
certain things because of certain brain
processes blah blah blah and that's all
there is to it or what is that yeah it's
it's evolution
i mean i mean in order to understand um
our current morality and views about it
we have to think about our ecological
history and the way that our attitudes
to other people have evolved in a
survivalist sort of scenario so i don't
see
i i know that science at the moment
can't say
this is good and this is bad but i think
to understand it you can use science and
you look back over the way that we have
emerged from the cave and have come to
the current day and and that illuminates
morality okay well that's interesting
because you see i think this this gets
to something it's potentially fruitful
it seems to me that the the scientific
kind of view is adopts a kind of a
highly reductive view in the sense that
nothing genuinely
genuinely importantly different can
emerge from the more fundamental uh
building blocks of the universe and the
morality is a good example because if
you take somebody who's a little less
head banger issue about this like
patricia churchman just a church is
often characterized as being kind of a
sort of a fundamentalist she isn't she's
very clear she says that what you
understand through neuroscience and
everything is the neural platform on
which morality sits and evolution
explains how it emerged but but i think
most of us would think that yes you can
tell that story that's true but what has
emerged
takes on a life of its own we are not
really slaves to this because otherwise
you would never be able to make a
distinction between what we have evolved
to judge to be right or wrong and what
is actually right or wrong so if someone
could show that we have evolved to to
to to to think like say rape is a good
thing right because if you vote to
approve a rape because it it helps to
sort of mix up the gene pool or
something you'd have no argument against
that unless you could show that it
hadn't evolved whereas actually what
evolution has done and the neuro and the
brain has done has developed the
capacity for us to engage in thoughts
which somehow take us to another level
of organization and complexity so things
emerge out of the basic physical nature
of the world which can't be then reduced
back into them and i think that's that's
the how i would see it i'm not ganesha
you know do you can you respond to the
kind of
can't get an or yeah i mean sort of so i
thought i agreed with you to start uni
and then and then i sort of found myself
thinking yeah but
we're not trying to reduce it back to
that right it's science science
is about trying to understand
that where that the the physical
elements of our existence right it's not
and consciousness is a difficult one
because as as philip pointed out you
know
we have it right now right we all of us
in this room have a sensation an
understanding of i myself am here and
doing this kind of thing so you know
that is undeniably a problem but also
you know
if i said animals aren't conscious
people would have to i hope at least
most of you would disagree with me right
so this this sort of idea that somehow
consciousness is something that happens
other that doesn't relate to our
physicality i don't think is completely
true oh no no obviously sorry it does
relate to our physicality that you
without the physical
um foundations of it it would not be
possible i'd agree with that so but so
then the the premise of science is just
to if you understand
the foundation that you spoke of if you
understand the foundation you understand
the scope the playing field within which
we are playing surely that's that can
only be a good thing know what i don't
think anyone's denying the fact that
there's you know relevance to or the
fact that human beings
you know
clearly have systems that that allow
them to operate in ways in which
aren't completely in keeping with what
our biology tells us to do i mean else
right now i'd just be snacking you know
um
is that that sort of i mean i'm not
joking about that
but you see what i'm saying i'm saying
that i i don't see that the pursuit of
science the belief that uh the
scientific method gives us an accurate
representation of our bodies of
ourselves of the world that we're in not
ourselves excuse me our bodies and the
world that we are in
is it i don't think it takes away from
the pursuit of trying to understand how
we feel about that and what does that
mean and where does that come from
i i don't see those as mutually
exclusive well i'm not okay we're not
sure we're
entirely connecting because i don't
think so either the question is whether
or not that scientific account exhausts
all that can be meaningfully said about
this that's a scientism thing
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas